à
offensive humanitaire et diplomatique de
la france pour la paix au liban deux
bateaux sont en route pour beyrouth
accalmie précaire des bombardements
aujourd'hui les rénovateurs de
l'opposition au pied du mur réunion du
conseil national du rpr demain pour
qu'ils renoncent sous peine d'exclusion
à ses mandats par michael gorbatchev à
londres nouvelles propositions pour
accélérer le désarmement la reine
d'angleterre invité en union soviétique
duel franco américain san diego pour les
coupes davis yannick noah affrontera
john mcenroe et henri leconte andré
agassi
madame monsieur bonsoir la france prend
la tête d'une offensive européenne pour
tenter de sauver le liban ou ce qu'il en
reste
les pays membres de la communauté
européenne font effectuer une démarche
commune auprès de la syrie pour obtenir
un arrêt des bombardements et une
reprise du dialogue entre les
différentes factions libanaises
paris cherche aussi à obtenir une
réunion du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
voilà pour les efforts diplomatiques
parallèlement à ceux ci deux bateaux
français d'assistance humanitaire ont
appareillé en fin de matinée
destinations beyrouth
patrice pollet
sous l'objectif des amis la rance a
quitté l'arsenal de toulon dans six
jours le bâtiment sera opérationnel au
large des côtes libanaises mission
humanitaire de soutien médical auprès
des populations civiles
un véritable hôpital flottant une
centaine de lits deux blocs opératoires
pour 34 médecins infirmiers
anesthésistes tous militaires
leur première mission en zone de guerre
sur ce bateau sommes très bien équipé
ensuite ça pourrait paraître plus
compliquée mais le personnel est là
disponible 24 heures sur 24
il n'y a que des professionnels que des
gens qui ont l'habitude de travailler
dans l'urgence dans la traumatologie et
donc ça devrait mieux se passer qu'à
terre dans les cales des tonnes de
produits de première nécessité
médicaments conserve lait en poudre port
de déchargement prévu beyrouth
mais la rance bâtiment militaire n'est
pas un navire-hôpital protéger d'où
l'inconnue de cette mission commencera
reçu là bas le geste de la france pour
les chrétiens libanais c'est avant tout
une mission humanitaire dans un dans un
milieu très instable je pense que les
risques ne sont pas énormes pour pas les
maximiser il faut pas les minuit c'est
non le bâtiment est équipé pour assurer
son autodéfense sa protection rapprochée
et c'est tout à bord deux hélicoptères
sanitaire 170 hommes dont 40 appelés du
contingent
ils sont partis ce matin aidé le liban
éclaté à retrouver l'espoir
le second bâtiment pétrolier transporte
du carburant pour la centrale électrique
qui alimente tous les quartiers de
beyrouth et qui est presque à sec
jean françois deniau l'émissaire
français est rentré à paris après s'être
efforcés hier soir sans succès
d'organiser une rencontre entre les deux
chefs de gouvernement libanais le
chrétien aoun et le sunnite hausse
roland dumas a lancé tout à l'heure un
appel pour que la mission humanitaire
française puisse être mené à bien
ces bateaux précise le quai d'orsay sont
partis avec l'accord des autorités
libanaises et davin ça en a été informé
damas qui ne ménage pas ses critiques à
l'égard de paris
à beyrouth la vie un timidement repris
ses droits aujourd'hui à la faveur d'une
accalmie précaire des bombardements
jérôme boni dont lé de 13 à beyrouth
les obus sont encore tombés ce matin sur
le port de jounieh ou s'embarque les
civils fuyant vers chypre pourtant les
combattants chrétiens à bout de forces
après 25 jours de pression de l'armée
syrienne et des alliés musulmans
semblent avoir répondu à l'appel au
cessez le feu lancé par la ligue arabe
les rares beyrouthin rester dans le
secteur est on profitait de ce semblant
de répit pour sortir prudemment de leur
abri et découvrir leur ville en ruines
le pétrole brut ou jours dans le port
les sources d'énergie s'épuise
il n'y a plus qu'une heure d'électricité
par jour
après les prises de position officielle
de la france les combattants chrétiens
se sont arrachés drapeau tricolore et
poster du président mitterrand
pour eux la pression diplomatique
internationale sur la syrie est devenue
une planche de salut à damas au
contraire les démarches française au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu sont
ressentis comme un défi par le
gouvernement syrien qui continue
d'affirmer malgré les opérations de son
contingent de 37 de 3500 hommes au liban
qu'il s'agit d'un conflit libano
libanais à jérusalem violents
affrontements en ce premier jour de
ramadan sur l'esplanade des mosquées
doma
l axe à une dizaine de personnes ont été
blessées tôt israéliennes comme
palestiniennes sur place charles
enderlin la prière vient de se terminer
la foule se disperse mais quelques
centaines de mètres plus loin des jeunes
organise une manifestation des drapeaux
palestiniens interdits ont été
introduits dans les mosquées
en dépit des contrôles de police très
vite c'est l'accrochage avec les forces
de l'ordre les manifestants prennent
pour cible le balcon se troue les
journalistes des policiers sont
installés à proximité
le cameraman qui a tourné ces images a
été légèrement blessé quatre
palestiniens touché par des balles en
caoutchouc sont hospitalisés les fidèles
juifs qui se trouvait devant le mur des
lamentations n'ont pas été touchés par
les pierres qui tombaient de l'esplanade
des mosquées
il y à plusieurs dizaines d'arrestations
la police israélienne se paie par un
mois de ramadhan agitée à jérusalem
yasser arafat est née palestiniens des
territoires occupés sont loin
d'applaudir à la proposition faite hier
à washington par itzhak shamir pas
question d'accepter des élections dans
le cadre de l'occupation israélienne du
style le président américain george bush
a lui réaffirmé aujourd'hui son soutien
à cette proposition tout en prônant une
politique de petits pas au proche orient
branle bas de combat au were père le
conseil national du rassemblement qui
compte plus de 300 membres est convoqué
demain après midi à paris l'objectif
faire rentrer dans le rang les
rénovateurs oublé novateur qui
souhaitent leur propre liste aux
européennes et qui ont reçu hier soir
ici même un soutien de prix celui de
madame simone veil
le jeu a assez duré dirais plutôt
sèchement ce matin alain juppé sur notre
antenne menacé d'exclusion
les cadets sont au pied du mur roland
sicard
on les croyait sages comme des images au
fond de la classe près du radiateur
et voici que les jeunes se rebiffe les
rénovateurs sont au nombre de douze 12
qui prennent la parole sans lever le
doigt pour chahuter les professeurs
valéry giscard d'estaing et jacques
chirac
une affaire qui n'aurait peut être
mérité qu'une simple observation sans
l'intervention de simone veil simone
veil qui a annoncé hier soir sur antenne
2 qu'elle prenait sa carte jeune et
distribuer les bonnets d'âne à la liste
d'union patronné par giscard et par
chirac
j'avais dit très clairement que je ne
pouvais pas cette liste d'union telle
qu'elle se présentait ce n'est pas ma
démarche politique
c'est une ce n'est pas tellement sur le
plan je dirais européen où il pointe
sont approchés ils sont comme en 1984 il
ya de grandes divergences
il ya aussi des convergences mais je
prends que c'est une démarche politique
qui entretient la confusion qui n'est
pas claire simone veil qui rejoint les
jeunes et elle n'est pas las le
professeur alain pompidou le fils de
l'ancien président de la république
khalid lui aussi la bombe 10 12 je
soutiens leur initiative qui me paraît
bonne qui me paraît proche de ceux dont
les hommes et les femmes de ce pays ont
besoin c'est à dire
un goût du mieux-être mais dans la
dignité et dans la dignité par rapport à
la france
simone veil alain pompidou cela commence
à faire désordre et les anciens du rpr
ont décidé de se fâcher
alain juppé toujours sur antenne 2
sortait ce matin sa règle les candidats
à la liste jeunes risquent bien de se
faire taper sur les doigts ne peut pas
être à la fois sur deux listes
il y aura une liste officiellement
investi ce qui rompt sur d'autres listes
n'appartiendront plus de leur fête au
rpr de l'exclusion dans l'air tout
devrait se jouer au cours du week-end
le conseil national du rpr a été avancée
à demain les rénovateurs se
rencontreront dimanche
le dernier axe annonce à grand spectacle
on ne débat pas si on menace d'exclure
c'est la réplique de michel barnier l'un
des cadets aux propos d'alain juppé
commentaire du cds bernard stasi
aujourd'hui nos positions et maintenant
condamnés à se rénover 34 jeune député
rpr mais orthodoxe cela lance bien sûr
un appel en faveur de la liste unique
la plupart des rénovateurs même
peut-être philippe seguin assisteront
demain au conseil du rpr tout autant
qu'eux mais de l'autre côté jacques
chirac est lui aussi au pied du mur
jean-louis lesaint et oui christine
devant le raz-de-marée le président du
rpr a dû se résigner se résigner d'abord
avoir ton entreprise des novateurs autre
chose que l'opération d'un quarteron de
khadra génère près c'est de lui faire
prendre sa retraite se résignait a
menacé d'exclusion les moutons noirs se
résignait à précipiter la convocation du
conseil national du mouvement prévu à
l'origine pour le 20 avril se résigner
enfin lui qui depuis sa défaite aux
présidentielles ne prise guère les
médias à ouvrir à la presse
l'intégralité des travaux qui se
déroulent d'habitude à huis clos
courageux jacques chirac prend un risque
il le sait montrer au public qu'il est
déstabilisé mais il peut aussi bien
piéger ce qui lui bouderait lui ceux qui
voudraient faire de l'esbrouffe ou en
prenant en compte certaines aspirations
des frondeurs retourner la situation à
son avantage
demain tout le monde sera là et tout le
monde devra se dévoiler les novateurs
comme la droite chiraquienne un remake
aux grands
en quelque sorte des journées
parlementaires de nice entre charles
pasqua et michel noir les juges de ce
combat seront presque 400 les 400 dans
la terre de ce parlement du rpr qui
devront dire si la base gaulliste
comprend qu on les tape les ans 80 à ne
pas voter giscard qu'on est encouragé à
voter veille dans 84 et qu'on lui dise
aujourd'hui de voter giscard et ne pas
voter veille avouez qu'il ya de quoi
être déboussolé
mais il paraît que c'est ça aussi la
politique si vous le dites en corse à
bastia
les négociations entre les préfets et
les syndicats suspendu pendant quelques
heures viennent de reprendre la journée
s'est ainsi déroulée par à-coups sur
place à bastia christophe martet les crs
de bastia ont inauguré le cordeau
antibruit alors qu'auparavant la place
résonnait du martèlement lancinant des
pierres sur les grilles
celle ci reste désormais hors d'atteinte
un calme plat
à l'image des premières heures de ce
deuxième jour de négociations ponctuées
seulement par des suspensions de séance
et quelques déclarations il faudra
attendre 18h30 pour que les préfets
s'assied à nouveau à la table des
négociations avec semble-t-il en cloche
de nouvelles propositions le
gouvernement serait prêt à donner plus
sur la prime de transport notamment les
syndicats discutent actuellement du
protocole d'accord proposé par les
préfets le dialogue est renoué
mais jusqu'à quand ici après deux jours
de chassé croisé
chacun a appris à rester patient
les responsables syndicaux nationaux
dans à nouveau de la voix aujourd'hui
michel rocard fait l'édredon estime marc
blondel de force ouvrière pour louis
viannet de la cgt le gouvernement est en
train de prendre les travailleurs corses
en otage l'économie française va bien
croissance record en 88 3% et demi le
meilleur résultat depuis 76 c'est ce
qu'affirme la commission des comptes de
la nation
les prévisions de croissance restent
très favorables pour les deux années à
venir
alors qu'aux états unis il est
redescendu à 5% de la population active
de chômage reste bien sûr chez nous le
problème numéro un
le ministre du travail jean pierre
soisson a ouvert aujourd'hui avec les
syndicats des négociations sur la
réforme du droit de licenciement
il ne s'agit pas pour lui de revenir sur
la suppression de l'autorisation
administrative de licenciement mais de
mieux protéger par une loi des
travailleurs les plus âgés dans l'ariège
les licenciements sont devenus une
affaire collective depuis l'annoncé
cette semaine de plus de 700
suppressions d'emplois chez roudière
le premier fabricant européen européen
de tissus établie à laval ave le nez
c'est la vallée la plus industrielle du
département qui est ainsi frappés par la
crise du textile
jean-pierre bêtise est et christian tu
si c'est une entreprise de fabrication
de tissus qui avait à peu près 45
employés et s'est arrêté il ya deux mois
ça fait quand même un chômeur le textile
et est implantée depuis plus de 110 ans
et c'était la seule ressource de tout le
voilier est du pays dans le monde il y
avait comme une entreprise de
l'entreprise
à l'époque il devait y en avoir dans les
quarante à cinquante ans de prison et il
en reste deux sans compter la centaine
de façonniers des ruines industrielles à
présent celles ci étaient centenaires 80
employés bilan déposé il ya cinq ans
la filature montariol 25 personnes fermé
voici un an autour de lavelanet 20000
personnes dans la vallée d'olmes
vivaient du textile heureusement il y
avait roudière le roi du tergal en
europe
repris par les chargeurs de jérôme
seydoux en 1987
aujourd'hui tout bascule concurrence
asiatique robotisation routière va
licencier 729 employer un salarié sur
trois et personne ne sait encore qui
sera sur la liste reçoit jeunes à
l'entreprise mais ça passe à l'elysée un
ancien jean-pierre bertha 39 ans textile
déjà licencié en 1981
lui n'aurait jamais cru que le géant
roudière puisse pas cillé enfin c'est
pas qu'on arrive à les recevoir sa coupe
les jambes il a plu presque plus envie
d'aller au vert
tout petit leur certaines productions
seront abandonnés ici qui pourrait
devenir rentable pour de petites
entreprises routières leur garantirait
du travail pendant trois ans ce qui
suppose aussi que l'état injecte des
capitaux il me semble que c'est le seul
exploit de notre région à la création de
ce réseau de pme l'espoir au delà du
château cathare de monségur dans une
autre vallée il est une ville saint
girons dont le maire roger fauroux
ministre de l'industrie alors ici on se
prend à rêver que des faits viennent à
nouveau se pencher sur la vallée d'olmes
awa exciting la reine d'angleterre
officiellement invité en union
soviétique mikhaïl gorbatchev qu'elle
recevait à déjeuner aujourd'hui au
château de windsor le lui a proposé elle
n'a dit ni tout à fait oui ni
franchement non ce matin à l'hôtel de
ville de londres
le président soviétique relancer son
offensive pour le désarmement à londres
george porte ni gorbatchev chez la reine
les gorman offres reçues par le couple
royal au château de windsor
ces images ont évidemment un sens
politique monsieur gorbatchev ne veut
plus être seulement le secrétaire
général d'un parti communiste au pouvoir
depuis très longtemps
il veut être aussi un chef d'état et
c'est à ce titre qu'il a invité la reine
à venir à moscou
la reine a remercié mais elle dit
qu'elle ne pouvait pour l'instant fixé
aucune date pour sa visite
le cérémonial était aussi impressionnant
ce matin au guildhall la maison des
corporations de la cité le nom les
hommes politiques des hommes d'affaires
étaient là pour entendre monsieur
gorbatchev parler de perez roque et
surtout de désarmement avec un
avertissement très ferme aux occidentaux
ne modernise et pas votre arsenal
nucléaire sinon nous nous risquons fort
de ne pas réduire nos armements
conventionnels
monsieur gorbatchev a donc visiblement
repris sa grande campagne pour obtenir
petit à petit progressivement une
élimination complète des armes
nucléaires de notre continent européen
l'intéressant c'est qu'il est venu dire
ça chez madame thatcher qui lui répond
très fermement mais pas du tout les
occidentaux ont besoin de garder et de
moderniser leurs armements nucléaires
monsieur gorbatchev il est vrai peut
avoir un accueil beaucoup plus favorable
en juin lorsqu'il ira en allemagne voir
le chancelier kohl dans le même discours
mikhaïl gorbatchev annoncé l'arrêt par
son pays de la production d'uranium
enrichi à des fins militaires
une décision sans réelle portée puisque
les stocks sont suffisants estime ce
soir match est numéro un soviétique
avait par ailleurs fait sensation en
donnant pour la première fois l'état de
ses forces armées
4 millions deux cent cinquante huit
mille hommes 1 million plus que les
états unis une première encore le
ministre français de la défense
jean-pierre chevènement
a été le premier occidental depuis la
guerre autorisés à visiter au nord-ouest
de l'union soviétique la base navale
ultra secrète de severomorsk laurent
boucher l'accompagné une ville interdite
une base navale qui jusqu'à présent
était un des endroits les plus secrets
du monde pour la première visite d'un
ministre étranger sur la presqu'île de
plats la marine soviétique soulever un
coin du voile de sa puissante à 250 km
au nord du cercle polaire arctique
mais situés sur une ligne très rarement
prise par les glaces celeron morte le
siège du commandement général de la
flotte du nord
c'est d'ici que partent les bâtiments de
combat soviétique qui tout au long de
l'année patrouille dans l'océan
atlantique
- 6° en pleine journée au mois d'avril
mais des dizaines de frégates et de
croiseurs à propulsion nucléaire
des milliers de marins et même le bac ou
l'un des deux porte avions de la marine
russe
pour un occidental le spectacle est
inédit à quelques kilomètres derrière
ces collines se trouve la plus
importante base de sous marins
nucléaires d'union soviétique évidemment
nous n'avons pas pu y aller mais le
simple fait de se trouver ici sur la
presqu'île de kola au siège du
commandement opérationnel de la flotte
du nord est un signe de la glace 9,2 de
l'ouverture que veut imposer michael
gorbatchev à l'institution la plus
importante du rss la défense halte au
saccage la forêt amazonienne nous vous
montrions hier le désastre écologique et
financier provoqué par le projet
inachevé de la transat à zone yens au
brésil et bien hier soir le président du
brésil rejeté ces accusations et annoncé
un projet ambitieux pour préserver les
quelques 5 millions de kilomètres carrés
de forêt tropicale une forêt saignée par
une route inachevé mais aussi par un
défrichement systématique et par la soif
de l'or
bernard benyamin pierre moskvich
c'est la fin de la transamazonienne des
400 km de pistes praticables d'une route
qui en faisait quatre mille pour passer
de l'autre côté du rieth apajh hausse il
faut prendre le bac une demi-heure de
traverser avant d'atteindre itaï touba
la ville les chercheurs d'or
des marchands d'or il y en a plus que
des boulangers ou des épiciers eyetoy
touba point de départ obligé pour le
gard hymne au la mine d'or
et comme tout se fait ici par avion
l'aéroport de cette petite ville de 15
mille habitants est devenue le deuxième
du pays en mouvement d'appareil
c'est que la transamazonienne n'existe
plus la forêt la dévorer
une heure de vol et c'est l'arrivée
alaminos galipeau mot magique pour les
brésiliens qui s'y sont rués à la fin
des années 70 avec l'ouverture de la
route et pour faire fortune
on supporte tout compte l'eau et la
terre pour y découvrir parfois les abus
le spectre
mais pour séparer l'or de la boue on
utilise ici un produit mortel pour la
faune et la flore de la forêt le mercure
pour chaque kilo d'or il é à 1 kg de
mercure poison violent rejetés dans
l'eau des rivières que voiron à quelques
centaines de kilomètres de là les
indiens d'amazonie
caro galipeau on ne voit pas d'eau on
préfère acheter jusqu'à 5 dollars la
canette de bière et dépensé une bonne
partie de ses gains aux barques de la
mine où les armes sont interdites
et de fait la vie coûte cher aux galets
ou alors on échange ses pépites contre
un pot de café ou un sac de riz
parce qu'il faut bien vivre en attendant
le filon d'autant qu'on travaille sur
des concessions cédé par un homme à qui
on reverse une partie de son or cet
homme c'est jouant kovacy les
multimillionnaires et il rejette les
critiques sur l'emploi de mai recul
qu'on nous attaquent sur ce point c'est
une honte on préfère parler du mercure
que de la situation du pays et celle de
l'amazone mari on nous a donné une route
n'existe plus et on voudrait nous
accuser maintenant de polluer notre
région avec ce mercure
c'est le gouvernement qui est
responsable de ça qu'il ouvre une
nouvelle route et on verra après parce
que celle que nous avions n'existe plus
c'est sur le chemin du retour que nous
allions rencontrer la deuxième plaies de
l' amazonie les feux de forêt un chiffre
un seul pour comprendre l'ampleur de la
catastrophe
en cinq ans plus de 700 mille kilomètres
carrés de forêt ont été brûlés ce qui
correspond à la superficie de la france
et de l'angleterre réuni responsables
les chercheurs d'or mais aussi tous ces
propriétaires terriens qui cherche
d'agrandir leur exploitation il envoie
des paysans sans terre qui défrichent et
brûle à tour de bras avant de les
expulser parfois de les tuer lorsqu'il
refuse de partir
chaud au début nous avons essayé
d'apporter notre assistance aux paysans
qui voulait s'installer dans cette
région mais très vite on a été dépassés
on ne peut pas contrôler un territoire
aussi grand que l'amazonie il faudrait
avoir une police des airs qui pourraient
repérer les feux et donner la lèvre on a
déjà assez de mal à maintenir en état la
route ou ce qu'il en reste
tout au long de l'année c'est ainsi que
l'enfer vert comme on l'appelait
disparaît peu à peu enfumée poumon de la
planète ou formidable réserve de faune
et de flore peu importe car aujourd'hui
c'est un véritable continent de 5
millions de kilomètres carrés que l'on
est en train d'assassiner le président
bush annoncé aujourd'hui que l'armée
américaine allait participer au
nettoyage de la marée noire provoquée
par le pétrolier valdez le capitaine du
valdez qui a été libéré sous caution a
été inculpé entre autres de commandement
en état d'ivresse
eh bien on découvre aujourd'hui qu'il
était certes l'un des plus jeunes
commandant de la marine marchande
américaine
mais on découvre aussi qu'on lui avait
retiré deux fois son permis de conduire
sans permis de conduire voiture pour
cause d'alcoolisme
joseph hazlewood était venue en france
il ya onze ans suivre un stage dans une
école unique au monde apport revel près
de grenoble
il s'agit d'une école de pilotage des
groupes pétroliers qu'emmanuel vanier a
vite
un accostage raté ici un incident bénin
mais dans un port normal il aurait pu
avoir de graves conséquences apport
revel heureusement l'océan a les
dimensions d'un lac
l'erreur est permise mais halak où les
conditions de navigation ont été
fidèlement reconstitués à l'échelle bout
et balises ponton d'accostage un
véritable port en miniature
ici le canal de suez avec ses virages et
ses écluses difficile à négocier
pauvre revel c'est une école unique au
monde l'intérêt de cette école pour le
navigateur et de lui fournir un outil
qui permet d'exercer son métier dans un
monde miniature sans risque pour
l'environnement et pour la et pour le
navire
c'est à dire qu'il va surtout essayer
d'aller à ses limites et à celle de son
navire tout en sachant qu'ils ne
risquent rien les bateaux des modèles
réduits au 25e de navires ayant existé
l'europe c'est un pétrolier de 250 mille
tonnes stoven abord un capitaine
uruguayen les manoeuvres sont exactement
les mêmes que sur un véritable navire
les réactions parfaitement identiques
ici on apprend à piloter en eau
difficile en zone restreinte disent les
marins
là où les accidents sont les plus
fréquents quand vous voulez arrêter des
navires comme ça quand ils sont à une
vitesse de 12 noeuds par exemple ce qui
fait 3 km 500 à 600 l'heure il vous faut
à 2 noeuds il faut 300 mètres pour
l'arrêter quand on met des machines on a
mis en route une barrière tout quoi si
vous pouvez donc 300 m c'est pas une
petite distance devant port ici grâce au
générateur de houle on analyse la dérive
des navires pour revel a été créé il ya
22 ans près de grenoble par la compagnie
pétrolière exxon pour former des
capitaines des tout nouveaux
superpétrolier indépendante aujourd'hui
l'école a déjà accueilli trois mille
cinq cents stagiaires venus du monde
entier
ici je peux faire de nombreuses
manoeuvres en une semaine alors qu'en
mer j'en fais très peu peut-être un jour
une semaine de stage pour apprendre à
dompter les monstres des mers piloté un
supertanker dit on ici c'est comme
conduire un camion de 30 tonnes sans
frein sur une route verglacée
avec pour tout moteur celui d'un vélo
solex
un avion de tourisme s'est écrasé ce
matin sur l'aéroport de nice éric perrin
aucun survivant dans l'accident d'un
avion de tourisme à l'aéroport de nice
l'appareil en provenance de bastia s'est
écrasé avant de prendre feu le pilote et
les trois passagers sont morts
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
le crash serait dû à une erreur de
pilotage
premières négociations cet après midi
dans les locaux d'antenne 2 entre des
représentants des diffuseurs des
producteurs et des syndicats de comédien
ces derniers en grève depuis plus de
deux semaines protestent contre le non
respect des accords qui devait leur
assurer un minimum de journées de
travail
ce mouvement intervient alors que ces
mêmes artistes s'inquiètent des risques
qui pèsent sur la production d'oeuvres
de fiction européenne
inculpation de l'animateur du centre
d'instinct côté rapide montre à mes
guy-claude burj et qui développait ce
qu'il appelle une thérapie fondée sur la
consommation d'aliments crus que l'on a
auparavant renifler a été inculpé
d'exercice illégal de la médecine et de
publicité mensongère elle vienne en
autriche arrestation de deux infirmières
soupçonnèrent soupçonné d'avoir tué en
les chargeant à l'insuline une dizaine
de patients san diego californie 1h30 du
matin demain heure française début des
quarts de finale de la coupe davis entre
la france et les états unis
henri leconte affrontera andre agassi
mais yannick noah disputera le premier
match contre john mcenroe
sept ans après grenoble un duel qui
promet d'être acharnée daniel cazals
yannick noah john mcenroe deux stars de
tennis mondial qui vont marquer de leur
personnalité
ce quart de finale de la coupe davis il
ya sept ans le 26 novembre 1982 leur
simple lors de la finale de grenoble
avait constitué un événement à
l'intérieur même de l'événement mcenroe
l'avait emporté en cinq sets
alors que noah avait mené deux manches à
une 7 ans après le goût d'inachevé
demeure et le français bien décidé à ne
plus laisser passer sa chance
si on se retrouvait même situation je
pense que le match on ne perdra pas avec
les honneurs qu'on aime comme on aime
tellement le faire on se prend plaisir à
faire en france si on se retrouve à
cette situation et c'est de gangania
quoi on gagnera c'est exactement ce que
pense john mcenroe fmi on arrive à san
diego mcenroe à nos âges se
rencontreront pour la cinquième fois
dans ce face à face
l'américain mène par quatre victoires à
0 en quarts de finale qui seront diffusé
par fr3 des joueurs professionnels de
basket ball aux prochains jeux
olympiques
c'est la décision de la fédération
internationale de basket réunit
aujourd'hui à munich
très vite encore les pronostics de
pierrette brès pour le tiercé quarté +
demain à vincennes
vous allez j'espère les découvrir sur
votre écran je vous les donne en tout
cas 16 partants ses pronostics le 3 le 8
le 16 le dise le cev le 4 le 12 et le 2
dans un instant laurent cabrol va vous
parler du temps de demain et du week-end
vers 22h50 dernier journal avec henri
sannier faux rendez vous avec
l'information sur antenne 2 avec daniel
bilalian et bernard rapp demain et
dimanche lundi 20h vous retrouverez
hervé claude je vous donne rendez-vous
dans une semaine
bonne soirée bon week-end